hi this is presh talwalkar a geometry
textbook has the following problem
a right triangle has a hypotenuse equal
to 10 and an altitude to the hypotenuse
equal to six
what is the area of the triangle
can you figure it out
the story goes a teacher asked this
problem to a class and every single
student quickly submitted a calculation
the teacher then said none of the
calculations were correct
can you figure out why
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
you can approach this problem by drawing
a diagram
we have a right triangle which has a
hypotenuse of 10
and an altitude to the hypotenuse equal
to 6.
the area of a triangle is equal to its
base times its height divided by 2.
to apply this formula it might help to
rotate the triangle
the hypotenuse of 10 becomes the base
and the altitude of 6 becomes the height
substituting those numbers in the
formula we get an area equal to 30.
but this is not the correct answer to
this problem
the reason is the dimensions of the
problem are not correct
let's see why
imagine we have a hypotenuse equal to
10.
if the two end points of this line
segment make up two points of the
triangle we want to know where can we
draw a third point where can the third
vertex be to make a right triangle
now not every point will make a right
triangle but some points will form a
right triangle
so we want to figure out the locus of
points where we can place the third
vertex to make a right triangle
here's how we can figure it out
if the third vertex forms a 90 degree
angle
then it's going to subtend an arc that's
180 degrees
so if we think about the hypotenuse as
the diameter of a circle
then the third vertex can be anywhere
else in the circle to form a right
triangle these are the only points that
will form a right triangle with that
hypotenuse of 10.
the altitude of the hypotenuse is the
vertical distance from this third point
to the hypotenuse
this will vary depending on which point
it is in the circle
so we want to know what's the largest
altitude we can make
well this will be when we move the
altitude all the way to this point
this is the largest possible altitude of
the right triangle and this is exactly
equal to the radius of the circle
this is one-half the diameter of 10
which means the largest altitude you
could have is equal to 5.
so the correct answer to this problem is
that there's a typo in the textbook
there is no right triangle that is a
hypotenuse equal to 10 and an altitude
to the hypotenuse equal to six at most
you can have an altitude equal to half
of the hypotenuse which would be five
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon
you can catch me on social media at
preshtalwalkar and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description